question to you then did you grow up
during the Toonami phase because I feel
like tsunami is has played such a big
factor into making the anime fans of
today know I hate for some reason I we
did we have to Nami in the UK we did we
did but you need it you need it sky TV
so I think you needed Cartoon Network
sky is like basically cable in the UK
yeah wait you guys didn't get continent
with just like free day no necessarily
it was free oh wow yes because I know my
parents paid because my dad wanted to
pay for the football matches in the UK
right and you basically up the whole
bundle so I watch the cartoon and stuff
and I remember there was like there was
loads of cartoons I never saw anime I
think it was airing really late and by
there my parents are like why aren't you
in bed son cuz when he was on the
tsunami um it was like Dragon Ball Z
Gundam Wing
I heard the same Dragon Ball never
watched it there cuz I just it was
always a mess cuz if they add it out of
order so I was going on I thought it was
cool but I couldn't get into it right
yeah I think Dragon Ball Z in Gundam
Wing were the only two I was able to
watch whenever because our family didn't
have sky TV so I can only watch it when
I go to my cousin's house and I'll be
watching episodes out of order Gundam
Wing made no [ __ ] sense still makes
like I'll be watching a scene and for
some reason the guy wants to kill this
girl but the girl still wants to get
what the guy makes no [ __ ] sense to
me
as a kid you know gunner he's already
confusing enough as it is
Dragon Ball Z was okay because I could
just watch I could skip 5 episodes and
they'd be the same cuz I remember like I
would have you watching these scenes in
Dragon Ball Z yeah and Goku was like
powering up the Spirit Bomb yeah and
then I'd go I I'd not be able to go to
my cousin's till like two weeks later
the Goku was still powering I was like
oh this is just the next episode no it
was like I missed like three four
episodes and it was it was just the
still the same [ __ ] to this day he's
still powering it on so hasn't